Speaker 1: OK, so we talked about
some elements of this seem like
Russia is pushing to take Ukraine and that
they ultimately will be able to. And it's a
matter of when, not if that that's the earlier
story we did about Russia seizing its first
major Ukrainian city. We now have to talk about
the numerous stories that have been published
and videos that have been published, so we know
that this is happening of crying Russian soldiers
surrendering all over Ukraine, and these are
legitimate, believable stories. Business Insider.
Some Russian troops are surrendering to
Ukrainian forces without a fight as morale drops.
U.S. defense official says some Russian troops
have been surrendering to Ukrainian forces
with no fight. The senior official said the
Russian military appears to be risk averse.
The official said among Russia's military
are young draftees who have never
faced combat. You've seen it on the ground where
units are surrendering, sometimes without a fight.
And they've got a lot of these soldiers are
conscripts never been in combat before. Some of
whom we believe weren't even told they were going
to be in combat. So we're just seeing evidence of
a bit of risk aversion. Russia's troops also
struggling with fuel and sustainment issues.
And we've we talked about that on yesterday's
bonus show. This convoy of tanks, which we will
talk about again on today's bonus show, reportedly
moving as slowly as three miles per day,
partially because the troops have a lack of food
and the tanks have a lack of gas. And if that's
the case, obviously we would welcome that. That
being said, this official says they will regroup,
they will adjust, they will change their
tactics. Another report captured Russian soldier
breaks down in tears after being humiliated by
Ukrainians, a Russian soldier was filmed crying
while being humiliated by Ukrainians as
the war following Russia's invasion rages
on. During the video, the soldier is seen sitting
some steps on some steps, sobbing with his face
in his palms. At the same time, a few people
standing in front of him are heard swearing
in. Ukrainian pictures and videos showing Russian
soldiers captured by Ukraine have been posted all
over the place. So how could both of these
things be true? How could, on the one hand,
Russia's forces be overwhelming and taking cities
and by by some indications, almost inevitably
ultimately going to take over Ukraine? And yet
there are soldiers crying? Well, it's because at
the individual level, many of these soldiers are
completely demoralized, and as the article says,
some weren't told that they would be facing
combat. Many have never faced combat,
and all of a sudden they are there and they are
just bailing at the same time. The forces are so
large Russian military forces that even if
you've got hundreds of demoralized troops saying,
What the hell am I doing here? I want to go home,
let me call my mom. There are enough to still
continue overwhelming Ukrainian cities. There's
one video here of and this there's examples of
everything. This is a surrendered Russian soldier
being treated well, being given food, being given
drinks and allowed to quite literally call mommy.
And I'm not saying that in a pejorative way. I
mean, we're talking about almost kids here who
are just being sent in to fight a battle many
of them don't want to fight and that very few
people actually understand. Take a look at this
Speaker 2: front, which is nine
miles from here and you've got
the guy. You could argue that the market is OK.
Speaker 1: And I understand that the audio alone,
unless you speak Ukrainian and or Russian, is
not super relevant. But there is an individual
here believed to be a Russian soldier who is
drinking what appears to be tea, being handed food
and Skyping Skyping with his mom and being
helped to do so by Ukrainians. And of course,
this doesn't mean that there aren't examples of
anything you can imagine taking place, but a very
interesting moment. And the question increasingly
is like who really wants to be doing this?
Are even. Ah, even the the Russian forces who were
not surrendering thrilled about this mission, and
a lot of these videos kind of tell us a lot
about not only what is going on, I mean,
they say a lot about the Ukrainian people
and many when Russian soldiers say, Hey,
you know what? I give up, I don't want to be here,
I don't want to do this. They are treated well.
But just about the dynamics on the ground, and
it's it's it's heartbreaking, quite frankly,
at the same time that such horrible things are
being done at the top level by Putin and others.
A lot of these soldiers and this is not
different than in the United States, I mean,
you could say that the predatory nature of
military recruiting in the U.S. also makes
victims out of a lot of these young people,
those who got sucked into the war in Iraq. And
I mean, listen, it's not news to most people in
our audience. There is a lot of victimhood here,
real victimhood, and it is disturbing to see. And
when these when these things take place like this,
where everybody says, Hey, you know
what? None of us want this. Let's all
sort of relate to each other as humans.
Nice moments, although unfortunately,
they don't change the Russian policy, and Putin
seems determined to keep going, at least for the
time being. We have so much more on today's show.
You can find me on Twitter at Packman and let me
know how long you think this is going to continue.
We have so much more to discuss right after this
short break. The David Pakman show is a viewer,
community supported program, we really depend
on your support to do what we do and whether you
listen to the podcast or watch a YouTube clip or a
live stream here or there. I would love for you to
sign up and join Packman dot com. We do offer some
great viewer perks. Listener perks When people
become members, including a daily extra show,
we do an additional show just for our members,
as well as providing commercial free audio and
video streams to you. Priority access When we do
viewer town halls, another one of which we should
really schedule the next one soon, we should do
that. Four March, for sure. And so many other
great things you can sign up at. Join Packman
dot com. If you I believe the normal membership
rates are very reasonable, but if you'd like a
discount, you can use the code. Wow. 22 to save